was ordinary income
tax ever created to stick around or was
it just there to
raise money pay off the debt and we
don't have it anymore until
another war happens or was it supposed
to be permanent from day one
well for a lot of people was supposed to
be permanent from day one
in fact they had tried to get it earlier
after lincoln got rid of it but lincoln
got rid of it under a threat by the way
just so you know
that the supreme court did question the
validity of the income tax
and uh he did pull that tax out quite
rightly
rightfully so but then they wanted to
have an income tax in there in the early
uh 1900 period and that was knocked down
it wasn't until we got the 19th a 16th
amendment
that really allowed the income tax and a
lot of people at that time
wanted it to be permanent the initial
income tax in 1913
did not contemplate world war one it
didn't
uh it wasn't until 1917 1918 that they
really pushed it way up now uh in 1916
uh they pushed it up to 15
with an inkling of a war coming on but
uh bottom line
is it was there basically to uh to
make sure that the rich the very very
rich the top
really very small percentage paid a lot
of the income taxes
and it was still a small source of
revenue for the whole government
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you